we started by
discussing covet 19. we are at the start
of the third wave in europe this
highlights
the importance of a fast and speedy
vaccination
vaccination is now finally progressing
steadily
additionally we see that now johnson
johnson is kicking in
in the second quarter and let me remind
you that
johnson johnson vaccine only requires
a single shot for full vaccination but
overall if we have a look
at the second quarter what is committed
it means that we are on track to achieve
our goal
that this summer we want to have 70
percent of the adult
population in the european union
vaccinated
i also presented to the leaders
the latest changes for the transparency
and export
mechanism for experts of covet 19
vaccines
you know that yesterday
we added to the scope of this mechanism
the criteria of reciprocity and
proportionality
just to be very clear we want to make
sure
that europe gets its fair share of
vaccines
and let there be no mistake the european
union
can be proud and is proud to be the home
of vaccine producers
who not only deliver to european
citizens but export
around the globe overall up to date
the total number of experts from the
european union
has risen to 77 million doses
that shows that europe is the region
that exports the most vaccines worldwide
and we will continue exporting also
through covax and to protect
humanitarian
and health workers around the world so
the bottom line is
we invite others to match our openness
you